[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday October 5th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Elon Musk wanted to buy Twitter then he
didn't now it seems he does again
late on Monday lawyers for musk passed
along a proposal to Twitter seeking to
return to the original terms of the 44
billion dollar deal and on Tuesday
Twitter said it would accept
the agreement could avert a high-stakes
trial that's set to begin October 17th
but musk has been so unpredictable
throughout this Saga so there's no
guarantees on what will happen next
joining us to discuss what's behind this
latest twist and what it could mean for
the future of Twitter is wsj senior
reporter Cara Lombardo hi Cara thanks
for joining me hi there
there's been so much drama in this deal
and now musk and Twitter are back where
they started why is that
well as with everything involving Elon
Musk we don't really know for sure why
the sudden change of heart but people
have a few guesses of course one is that
he was set to be deposed in preparation
for the trial later this week so that
could explain it and what about Twitter
what has Twitter said about Elon musk's
return to his original offer you know
unlike musk they've hardly said a word
this entire time other than that they
intend to close the deal on the original
terms and they've been basically saying
that same line for the past several
months as this is unfolded before we get
into the trial can you just remind us
what those original terms were and how
this all got started yeah so back in
April musk agreed to pay 54.20 a share
to buy Twitter for a total price of
roughly 44 billion dollars and at the
time he was very gung-ho about it he
actually told Twitter he was so
interested he agreed to waive due
diligence or the equivalent of like a
house inspection and wanted to finalize
the deal as soon as possible
that's where they were at the beginning
now they seem to be back where they
started but what was hanging over them
at the moment as you mentioned is this
trial that was going to take place in
just a couple of weeks what did we know
from the early hearings about what the
shape of that trial might be so what
happened was musk had a change of heart
on the deal in beginning in May in July
he
move to terminate the deal saying that
Twitter had misled him about his
business specifically he was concerned
that they underestimated the number of
bots on their platform
and then Twitter sued him to follow
through with the deal as was their right
in their merger agreement the trial was
set to be possibly you know the most
Monumental corporate Clash of all time
this is Elon Musk one of the best known
and most visible billionaire
entrepreneurs out there
facing off against Twitter obviously
ubiquitous social media company that
many of us use in our daily lives so
have any of the issues that he raised as
reasons to pull out of the deal been
addressed as far as We Know
so he raised a variety of issues over
the past several months as this has been
playing out and a lot of legal experts
kind of likened it to throwing things
against the wall to see what sticks he
took issue not only with the Bots but
also with the way Twitter was running
its business in the meantime before he
took control of it that he didn't like
that they had let some Executives go
without seeking his permission first so
he was trying a variety of things none
of which legal experts thought were
particularly strong arguments
as the case moved forward we've seen
musk add claims to the counter suit
including he Incorporated complaints
from the former head of security at
Twitter who came forward as a
whistleblower in August alleging
problems with the platform's data
security did it seem like those would
affect his chances of getting out of
this deal until recently we were
thinking maybe that's the one wild card
should he be able to find a Smoking Gun
courtesy of this whistleblower maybe
that changes the direction of the case
but so far we hadn't seen anything in
the whistleblowers report nor in what
has come out through Discovery so far in
the trial that appeared poised to change
the outcome so what are the next steps
that have to happen here well I think
the way it's it's playing out is Twitter
would like obviously some comfort that
musk will follow through with this
proposal to close the deal on the
original term so they've gotten the
Delaware judge who was to oversee the
trial involved their ha the two sides
are hashing out a potential plan to get
get the deal closed and assuming the
judge signs off on that plan they would
be well on their way to doing so
given that must
character what
what maybe expect to happen next so yeah
I mean that's the thing in a normal
scenario when two sides say hey do you
want to do this yes we probably want to
do that you expect now they can agree
and close the deal pretty quickly here
but it's musk and everything he's done
on this deal has been completely against
Norms so you know we have to wonder will
he actually follow through but hopefully
we'll get an answer pretty soon if they
do reach an agreement we expect the deal
could close as soon as within a week
all right that's our reporter Carol
Lombardo thanks for breaking this down
for us Cara thanks
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]